Devil Fruits are the embodiment of people's
dreams, that grow on the treasure tree Adam
on Laugh Tale. In other words, devil fruits,
the treasures of the sea, are part of the one
piece. [shanks calls them treasure of the sea]
At least that's gonna be my current answer to
the question, what Devil Fruits are and where
they originally came from. Yes, there is still
a lot we don't know about these magical
fruits, that give people incredible powers,
but there also is actually quite a trail of bread
crumbs for us to follow throughout one piece.
The most basic observation I can make,
when I look at a devil fruit like the
mera mera no mi, is that this is a
plant. A pretty extraordinary plant,
that will turn my body into fire,
yes, but nonetheless a plant.
It's a bad tasting fruit with a stem that
didn't just pop into existence, but that had to
grow somewhere. I think the smile factory on
Dressrosa, that is actually full of important
clues, is a great example for this. Now, as you
know, it seems like devil fruits can reincarnate
in a suitable fruit close to where the previous
user died, as we saw with Caesar's pet Smiley and
probably when Blackbeard took Whitebeards fruit,
but these two are people who know way more about
how these fruits work than most people. And
don't forget that they must have come from
somewhere in the first place. So there must be
some original place, where these fruits come from.
What’s up, my name is Manu, and even though
I really don’t have a green thumb when it
comes to keeping plants alive, why do I still
believe that this should be a tree and not,
I don't know, a devil fruit ranch, where you
grow all types of fruits in different ways?
Well first of all in Romance dawn, the one
shot that was the blue print for One Piece,
Luffy's fruit was explicitly stated to have
grown on a tree. But also because trees are
one of the most important symbols in one piece,
similar to how whales represent laugh tale,
as I discussed in my last video. We have
the sun tree eve, the treasure tree Adam,
the tree of knowledge on Ohara, the whale tree
on Zou, and the sacred trees both on shandora
and in Wano, that are believed to
hold the souls of their ancestors.
Now, what do you think do all
these trees have in common?
But how does this bring us to the
devil fruit tree on laugh tal-
oh what’s that? HUH! A Sponsor.
Well, that’s convenient.
As you can see, This video is
sponsored by **Honkai Impact 3rd.**
Honkai Impact 3rd is a free-to-play anime
style action role-playing game for both
mobile and pc. In the game you control a
team of up to three characters, known as
"[Valkyries](https://en.wikipedia.org/wiki/Valkyrie)",
in a real-time combat-system against various
enemies. The new version 5.5 brings
new character displays, the most
awesome probably being Durandal, who not only
is the first to get a black and white form,
but also a new battle suit display, as well as new
outfits for the characters. And since right now,
they’re celebrating their Global Server's 4th
anniversary, there are a ton of event bonuses
and gifts. You get a special 4th anniversary
emblem, a variety of upgrade materials,
37 supply cards and over 4000 crystals. The spring
event also includes a new S-rank battlesuit!
And if you download the game now, you can redeem
this gift code here on screen for 30 Crystals,
2888 Asterite, and a Herrscher trial
card! So make sure to check it out.
Yup, trees in one piece represent the
void century and the ancient kingdom.
Eve is connected to both Marijoe and fishman
island, with Poseidon and Joy Boys apology.
Ohara was studying a poneglyph and the true
history of the world. Both Shandora and Wano
were closely connected to or maybe even
part of the ancient kingdom. By the way,
You also have the giant jack on skypea, that
holds the golden bell. And we also have a number
of trees that literally hold souls. The tree
on thriller bark as well as kingbaum and the
entire forest on whole cake island, again close
to a road poneglyph. The whale tree on Zou,
is even more special, because it
combines both symbols, the tree
and the whale. Zou is connected to the ancient
kingdom AND gives direction to laugh tale.
And there is actually another very important
tree in one piece. This one right here [].
So what does drum island have to do with
everything? Well plants in one piece, are closely
connected to one specific group of characters:
Doctors. And this goes for devil fruits as well.
Chopper is seen using herbs to make medicine
and drugs, the mushroom that poisoned Hiluluk,
cherry blossoms, the herbs and medicinal knowledge
in theTorino Kingdom, Doc Q and his explosive
apples, Crocus being named based off the flower
on his head, Law wouldn’t be able to do any
advanced surgery (cutting drugs out of the kids)
without eating his devil fruit plant andBeladonna
of Amazon Lilly, being named after the flower
‘atropa belladonna’ which is a medical plant.
There is also Noland, who cures the Shandorans,
with his chestnut hat,And of course
the master of them all Dr. Vegapunk.
Drum island is an important link
here in many ways. For one the
image of a giant cherry blossom tree, yes, but
Drum island is especially famous for its doctors.
[Ho, the doctor form alabasta talking about drum]
Which got me wondering: Why? Yes,
chopper and Kureha are great doctors,
but what makes this country stand
out from other doctors like law or
the island that chopper went to
train on during the time skip?
Well there are two oddities on drum island,
that make it special from a medical perspective:
Dr. Kureha's long life as
well as choppers rumble balls.
The rumble balls are especially interesting
to me, because they seem to unlock the hidden
potential in CHopper's fruit. And did this
young reindeer, who was studying under a quack
really come up with such an advanced technology
all by himself? Or could there be some hidden
knowledge on Drum island about the real nature
of devil fruits. I also don't think it's a
coincidence that blackbeard want there, because
everything he does is planned out very neatly.
Also remember that Chopper himself
is connected to trees as well. []
Now, let's address the elephant in the room. Why
are there 3 big trees in the one piece world,
that all have an obvious biblical theme?
We have two trees called Adam and
Eve, both of whom lived in paradise.
In this garden called eden, there were
two special trees. The tree of life,
that grants immortality, as well as the
forbidden tree of knowledge. Just like the
tree of knowledge on Ohara. Eve was tempted by a
snake to eat an apple from the tree of knowledge,
the forbidden fruit, for which her and Adam
where made mortal and cast out of paradise.
This snake is often seen as an embodiment of the
devil. Now, this is of course pure coincidence,
the people of ohara were called devils
by the government for their research.
Oh yeah and I almost forgot, we are
talking about literal devil fruits here.
Now as you know, whenever Oda-sensei
takes inspiration for his story,
he never copies everything one to one, but
gives things an interning twist. The story
of Adam and Eve, in Christianity, Judaism and
Islam, represents the original sin of humanity.
Being seduced by the devil and
eating the forbidden fruit.
In one piece on the other hand,
the people of Ohara, like robin,
clearly are portrayed as good
people interested in truth, and
just painted as devils by the government. So I
think it's clear that in the world of one piece,
the government, in other words, Imu, the Gorosei
and the other celestial dragons represent god,
only that here, god is the bad guy. The tree
of knowledge on Ohara would then represent
the 'sin' of gaining the same knowledge as
the government and how they came into power.
As I discussed in detail in this video here,
there is a good chance, that the
life tree, that grants immortality,
is the sun tree eve, that seems to be located
inside the red-line reaching up towards marijoe.
It might be this tree that gives literal
immortality to the celestial dragons,
that live in 'paradise' on top of the red line.
By the way, as you know Marijoe is located
exactly where the red line crosses the grand
line, diving the world into four oceans.
And even though I'm not very religious, I found
that there is this line from Genesis, that reads
'A river watering the garden flowed from Eden;
from there it wasseparated into four headwaters.'
Another very interesting re-occuring theme
here, that I completely overlooked at first,
is that of the forbidden fruit being an apple.
The fruit of the devil being an apple. This
pops up quite a lot. Doc q's apples, the smile
fruits all being apples, smiley's devil fruit
reincarnating into an apple, Enel the god eating
an apple. There's definitely a pattern here.
So the only aspect of the
garden eden reference that has
no clear role yet is the treasure tree Adam.
The story goes that god made
eve from a part of Adam,
which would suggest that the sun tree eve
was made from the treasure tree Adam as well.
As Franky explains to us, once, long, long ago,
an endless war raged on an island. People died,
and the island was destroyed by a rain of
bullets and left in ruins. However, the people
kept coming back to rebuild the nation near a
giant tree, the only one that remained intact,
and that was Adam. Not only does that sound
suspiciously like the ancient kingdom to me,
but there is also the idea of rebirth,
not unlike the devil fruits themselves.
So could the treasure tree Adam
be the original devil fruit tree,
that grows on laugh tale? I think a big
hint here is its name, the treasure tree.
Treasure makes me think immediately
of the one piece. Not only that,
but devil fruits are called the treasures
of the sea. And when you think about it,
treasure and trees are a
theme in the story as well.
Nami's treasure is buried under the tangerine
trees. The library is under the tree on ohara,
the road poneglyph is under the whale tree. Also,
as I've discussed in these videos, I believe that
Laugh Tale was the left eye of Jaya, that
was swallowed by a giant whale and is now
at the bottom of the sea. The other city on jaya,
shandora also has a giant sapling growing, well at
least until the straw hats cut it down. And
if laugh tale was at the bottom of the sea,
that would explain why its called the treasure of
the sea and the fruits of the devil. After all,
the ancient kingdom would have been the devil
to the gods of the world government, just like
the people of ohara. These fruits now float to
the surface and are spread across the world.
Now at the beginning of all this,
I mentioned that Devil Fruits are
literally the incarnations of peoples
dreams. What do I mean by that?
Well this idea is part of Yuderon's
mega theory about one piece, that
once again blew my mind. The basis for
this idea are rogers last words. []
You have inherited will, that is first introduced
by dr Kureha back on drum island. Callback. I
already talked about the possibility that
devil fruits might actually inherit part
of the previous users will to whoever eats it.
People's dreams. And the passing of the ages,
that means that people's dreams are
inherited thought the ages and never die.
This idea is confirmed by none other than
blackbeard himself, who is not only and absolute
devil fruit nerd, but also seems to be the only
person who knows how to consume multiple fruits.[]
This man's most important statement is that
peoples dreams never end. I think
haki plays a role here as well.
Because we know that people can manifest
their wills into reality in this world.
We also know that souls are
not only real in one piece,
but that they are said to enter trees
in the cultures of Wano and Shandora,
that are both connected to the ancient
kingdom. Chapter 225, titled 'people's dreams'
has Hachi on the cover page, dreaming under a
tree of making takoyaki on a deserted island,
like the deserted laugh tale. And in general,
I don't have to tell you, that dreams is one of
the most important concepts in the entire story.
All the big trees in one piece collect something.
The tree of knowledge on Ohara collects wisdom.
The sun tree eve collects the sunlight, the trees
on SHandora collect souls and so I believe that
the treasure tree Adam collects people's dreams.
The dream to be a bird, the dream to be fire
itself or the dream to turn everything into a toy.
All these abilities are fantastical and
things that can only come from people's
imagination. And Oda-sensei might have made
that a quite literal part of the story. This
is why there are only smile devil fruits.
You can take the lineage factor from an
animal and try to merge it with a human, but you
can't make an artificial logia or paramecia fruit.
Now this possibility absolutely blew my mind,
but it gets so so much crazier
when you look at the big picture.
The idea that laugh tale and the devil
fruit tree are at the bottom of the sea
is part of a much much larger theory, that puzzles
together the biggest mysteries in one pice.
And that’s why you really shouldnt ignore
this video, because it will make you question
everything you thought you
have known about one piece.